What happened? You look really confused. Man, I need a sound effect — something that gives suspense — I don't get how to apply it. Should I just search the name on YouTube? I'll find… […truncated]
…it. But what name do I search? I don't know the name of a single sound effect. You know them, right?
But there are a lot of different types of whoosh — a fast short whoosh, or a long one.
Coogly-moogly whoosh [unclear]
And here's a fun thing — saying "whoosh" out loud actually sounds like the effect itself.
Whoosh.
Leave it. [unclear]
This sound effect is perfect for fast transitions, movements and dynamic reveals.
Whether it's a title animation or some object moving across the screen,
a whoosh is what you'll want.
You can tweak this by changing the pitch. If you push the pitch high,
the sound effect will feel a bit lighter, but if you take the pitch low, it'll sound like a really heavy, weighty whoosh.
The second sound effect is swoosh. Whoosh again? No — not whoosh, swoosh. What's this swooshing about? Look, whoosh and swoosh are very similar sound effects, but between the two… […truncated]
…there's also a very… […truncated]
…there's also a very small difference. Both sound effects are really the movement of ai… […truncated]
Well, you've genuinely added to my knowledge here. [unclear] Third is riser — you get it from the name, right? The sound effect that's rising…
…yes, that.
Riser sounds are essential to build anticipation and tension. Before a jum… […truncated]
Riser sounds are essential to build anticipation and tension. Before a jumpscare, before a big reveal, or before a drop in the music, a riser teases
that something big is about to happen.
Fourth is ambient sound. In life…
In life, if anything is too perfect, it feels off — it doesn't feel natural. Same with your video: if there's no noise in it at all… […truncated]
…then it feels too perfect. Say you're standing in a market, but not a single market noise comes through in your audio… […truncated]
…and to give a more immersive feel: if you're standing on the road, traffic; if you're sitting in a cafe, the sound of people talking; and if you're outside somewhere, bir… […truncated]
…the sound of birds chirping.
Including these gives the scene a real atmosphere. Whatever you need — traffic ambience, people chattering ambience, birds ambience — basically just tack that on. [unclear]
[unclear]
Including these gives the scene a real atmosphere. [unclear] Whatever you need — traffic ambience, people chattering ambience, birds ambience — basica… […truncated]
…basically whatever I need, I'll find it out there. Nice. Fifth is
Mo… […truncated]
…motion sound effects. Notice one thing about real life: in real life, even the tiniest
movements create sound. So if there's motion happening anywhere in your video but no sound effect on it, then
the video feels very empty. Meaning I'll have to put a sound effect on my stomach, right? Because my stomach feels empty.
Whatever. But even on that, if you put a sound effect, it'll definitely feel a bit more immersive.
Someone's walking, dragging something, or just snapping their fingers.
In short, every motion should have a sound effect.
For example, if you've animated some motion graphics, or you've opened a doo… […truncated]
For example, if you've animated some motion graphics, or you've opened a door, or you're flipping a page in the video — for every one of those,
you'll find sound effects on the internet, so download them and put them on. What's the point of all this effort — I'm still not getting work. Are you applying them in the right place,
or just slapping them on everywhere? […truncated]
Big companies don't just show up on YouTube. Bro, where have you been? This is already happening.
Companies are realising the value of social media,
and companies are shifting towards creator-driven content.
Have you heard about YAS… […truncated]
Have you heard about YAS? No, I haven't heard of that. Then how would you know?
So let me first tell you about YAS, and this video is sponsored by them.
YAS basically helps billion dollar companies become creators.
They have some really big clients, like Zerodha, Zoho, ClearTrip, GoQuick and many more.
But what do we get out of it? I'm telling you something that's for your own benefit, bro. YAS is looking for talented video editors with a passion for high
quality content.
Not just now — they are always hiring talented video editors, making it a great place to work.
The requirements are pretty simple: you should have knowledge of video editing, Premiere Pro, After Effects and storytelling. Hey, all of that I already […truncated]
…know.
So if you want to do something big in editing, and you want to build a lucrative career out of this field,
then believe me, this is one of the biggest and best opportunities you will ever get.
So the link to apply is in the description and in the pinned comment.
Go, fill it in, and bro, show them how much fire our subscribers have got.
So now let's continue our video. Let's move to the 6th point: cartoon sound effects.
For slightly light-hearted or funny content, or to give that kind of feel, you can use these types of sound effects.
These include sound effects like boing, slide, whistle or pop. Adding them, you can elevate your humour even further.
You can also put echo on these sound effects to give them a slightly goofier feel.
My favourite sound effect out of these is…
My favourite sound effect out of these is the disc scratch — I use it a lot. How am I supposed to learn all these names? Okay, let me tell you. Look, there are two ways. Fir… […truncated]
…first one is practice. The more you explore, the more things you keep learning… […truncated]
…like heartbeat sounds, a clock ticking sound, or heavy breathing sounds.
A fast heartbeat creates tension; slow breathing sounds can make a moment feel
personal, and fast breathing tells you the guy is completely freaking out. In a single
shot, let me put different sound effects on and show you the difference.
Hit and impact sound effects. If you want to give some dramatic emphasis to a scene, you can use this sound effect there — it makes moments quite powerful,
those moments. This sound effect is usually used in thrillers,
under the name "cinematic hit", to create more impactful trailers. And to give it a bit more heavy impact,
you can also layer a bass drop with this impact sound. You know that thing, the bass drop?
Yes, that one. Hit and impact also come in different variations, like metal, wood — so wherever you need a certain feel, use that one there.
9th is the whip sound effect.
A whip? Yeah, a whip — the thing that looks like this.
Its sound effect sounds just like it too.
No, no, I'm not going to hit you.
On fast cuts or fast moments, this works really well.
You can also use it on a punchline or a sudden reaction to give it a humorous touch.
In old-school action scenes, this same sound effect used to be used as well.
Oh, that one?
Yeah, exactly that one. And when you layer it with a whoosh,
you'll end up with all kinds of unique sounds.
10th is Foley sound effects.
I don't know whether you say "foley" or "fooly" — I can't remember it either… […truncated]
I don't know whether you say "foley" or "fooly" — I can't remember that either.
But Foley sounds are the sound effects that, instead of being shot at a real location, are recorded inside a studio.
Put it one way, they're fake sounds…
Put it one way, they're fake sound effects that sound completely real, but they're actually recorded sitting inside a studio.
Footsteps, clothes, or door creaks — this creates realism in the scene, and this is also where yo… […truncated]
Footsteps, clothes, or a door creak — this creates realism in the scene,
and this is also where you can make your own sound effects. Say I record a whoosh.
So I made that with my own mouth, and it sounds like this.
So… […truncated]
…we do that, so we get a little section of noise out of it. [unclear]
…let's get some decent noise. [unclear]
First we'll put a change on it — our pitch shifter. Let's drop that on and raise the pitch a little, because our whoosh is a bit heavy, it sounds too
…it's going "hoo hoo hoo". So let's set this to zero point [unclear], okay.
See, it sounds like a proper whoosh now, but the pitch still feels a little off. Let's bring the pitch down a bit more — let's make it 6. Listen to the pitch now. Now let's put
…a low-pass filter on it, let's add that. Now in this… now… so this is how you can make a soun… […truncated]
…nobody will ever find out. I've done this plenty of times. And let me give you another Foley example: if you need the sound of a bone breaking, you can take the sound of wood breaking […truncated]
…and mix it with a water splash. Or you can take the sound of a cucumber snapping… […truncated]
…a copyright claim coming in for a sound effect. I mean, look, besides YouTube there are other platforms too, like
freesound.org or Pixabay, where you'll get free sound effects. One more very important
thing: if you have to use a sound effect repeatedly — say you need a whoosh three or four times in a row
— don't use the same whoosh sound there. It sounds really odd, people pick up on it. But let's say you only have one sound: "no, we're po… […truncated]
…poor, we only have one whoosh sound effect" — then use the techniques I told you about: rev… […truncated]
…you'll find it in the description and in the pinned comment. It's a very, very good opportunity. And subscribe to the channel. All right, till then, bye bye.